elles ne sont plus que 7 dans cet enclos
du parc de la colombière ce dimanche à 8
heures du matin le cadavre d'une chèvre
naine du sénégal a été retrouvée égorgée
et dépecer en dehors de l'espace réservé
aux câpres c'est sur ce banc en pierre
que le ou les auteurs lui ont tranché
les pattes arrière avant de les emporter
l'annnonce de cet acte de cruauté a
suscité une vive émotion chez les
promenades
c'est la musique comme on peut
s'attaquer aux animaux comme ça il n'y a
pas de mots comme on dit quoi ouais ça
ne choque ouais ça me surprend mais ont
vite tellement vidéo nos amours
on va dire que pas très joli je pense
qu'il ya un problème au niveau de la
dir-est delà de la surveillance et puis
yahia c'est pas la première fois qu et
des animaux qui sont tués le parc a
connu de multiples vols d'animaux à
l'été 2011 six ans plus tôt une
quinzaine de bêtes avaient été retrouvés
égorgés dans leur enclos
les auteurs du méfait faute d' indices
n'avaient pu être appréhendé ce dimanche
les pancartes de vidéosurveillance et
les grilles facile à escalader n'ont à
nouveau pas été dissuasif il n'y a pas
de trace d'effraction visible assets à
cet endroit néanmoins c'est bien là que
l'auteur des faits s'est introduite cela
ne justifie sans doute pas dès à présent
des mesures exceptionnelles de
protection néanmoins nous avons une
surveillance et animaux sont protégés
puisque déjà il ya trois personnes qui
sont dédiés à leur suivi sont des
personnes des animaliers ils sont trois
ils s'occupent quotidiennement des
animaux la police municipale fait des
rondes régulièrement
et puis le parc ce parc ici est fermée
ce lundi
la mairie a déposé plainte les auteurs
de cet acte de cruauté sont passibles
d'une peine de deux ans de prison et de
30000 euros d'amendé